>>Male Presenter: Well, welcome everyone to
another Talks at Google event.
We're very, very pleased to welcome to the
barrio, Adam Shankman.
[applause]
I see you've got the horns sign down now.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: So, Adam, I gotta get this
list.
I gotta read from my notes here.
So, Adam is a director, producer, a dancer,
an actor, and a choreographer.
And we'll hopefully touch on each one of those--the
history of his career in this interview.
And he's also been a judge and is continuing
to be a judge on a talent show.
>>Adam Shankman: I only judge for money.
[laughter]
Otherwise, totally judgment-free.
>>Male Presenter: You're totally judgment-free?
>>Adam Shankman: Totally.
>>Male Presenter: We'll see.
On So You Think You Can Dance.
[whooping]
And he's produced the 82nd Academy Awards,
which in and of itself is just a--.
>>Adam Shankman: That was the Steve Martin
Alec Baldwin one.
The good one.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: He's also directed television,
so episodes of "Glee" and "Modern Family."
And as well as several films I'm sure you're
familiar with, things like "Hairspray," "The
Wedding Planner," "Bringing Down the House."
And most recently, he's just finished up on
"Rock of Ages."
So, I think we're gonna quickly cut to a trailer
of "Rock of Ages."
[plays trailer]
[club music]
[cheering]
>>Female Singer: Anyway you want it, that's
the way you need it.
>>Male #1: Tonight it's the Bourbon Room.
Stacee Jaxx.
>>Male #2: This place is about to become a
sea of swimming, ear-shattering music, and
puke.
So start drinking now.
>>Male #3: [ ]. Now go.
[rock music]
>>Female #1: Your first album gave birth to
some of rock's greatest anthems.
What's it like to be the Stacee Jaxx?
[cheering]
>>Male #4: Stacee, you made it?
>>Stacee Jaxx: Hey, man.
>>Male #4: This is "Hey, man."
>>Male #5: When I was
a kid, I wanted to be Stacee Jaxx.
[singing]
"Heaven isn't too far away."
>>Stacee Jaxx: You're a singer and you have
real talent.
>>Female #2: That stage is a pedestal.
When you're up there, you're untouchable.
[singing]
"Hit me with your best shot."
>>Female #3: This club is totally out of control.
>>Stacee Jaxx: Our whole existence is riding
on Stacee Jaxx.
>>Female #3: We're gonna shut them down.
>>Stacee Jaxx: Oh, my God.
I just threw up.
>>Male #6: Where?
>>Stacee Jaxx: In my pants.
>>Female #3: Oh.
>>Male #6: You want love?
Go after it.
I can guarantee you something more cool--fame.
>>Female #2: You wanna get respect, you gotta
take that stage.
>>Male Announcer: Ladies and gentlemen, the
icon of rock.
Stacee Jaxx.
>>Male #7: I'm gonna light this place on fire.
[rock music]
>>Male #8: Stacee Jaxx.
It gives into the arts.
[rock music]
[end trailer]
>>Male Presenter: Wow.
>>Adam Shankman: That just made me nervous.
[applause]
What have I done?
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: I was amazed how quiet that
trailer was.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: Very low key.
So, what attracted you to the material at
first when you--"Rock of Ages?"
I mean, did you have long hair in 1987?
>>Adam Shankman: Well.
Oh, God.
I had horrible Jew-fro.
[laughter]
And then, I got home from high school one
day and took a watermelon and filled it with
vodka and--
>>Male Presenter: That's what you do.
>>Adam Shankman: on a Wednesday after high
school.
And I hope my parents are watching this.
And then we decided what a great idea, we
were gonna cut my hair.
And I used to refer to it as the "Ellie Mae,"
because what they did is they had a giant,
curly top and then it was shaved.
And she actually went to the scalp at one
point around here.
And it was just like, long and curly back
here.
[laughter]
So, I--.
>>Male Presenter: Are you still friends with
these people?
>>Adam Shankman: Guess what.
One of them is now the president of NBC.
[laughter]
Jennifer Salke was actually the person.
And--.
>>Male Presenter: I wonder if that's on her
resume?
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
Hi, Jen.
But we are, but yeah.
I mean, I grew up.
My dad was in the music business.
And I grew up literally on the corner.
His office was at 92 hundred Sunset, which
is like Doheny, and it's the beginning of
The Strip.
And my first concert that I went to, when
I was 12 years old, was at The Roxy, but it
was The Cramps.
And the lead singer pleasured himself and
finished on stage at the concert.
And I was like, "Wow.
Music is weird."
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: He fulfilled his contract.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah, exactly.
But then, I was a huge Foreigner fan and a
huge Journey fan.
And I started going to--.
My first concert was actually David Bowie
at an arena.
But anyway, so this was kind of my time.
And what I remember about this time was that
it was the last period of our innocence, kind
of, because these people were running amok
like children and there seemed to be no consequences
for anything.
You would just throw a couch out of a hotel
window and it was like, "Yaaaah."
And you could have casual sex and there was
no AIDS.
And you never heard the word "rehab."
And they were just doing mountains of drugs,
but it was just all in fun.
I remember there's a brilliant documentary
called "The Decline of Western Civilization-The
Metal Years," that I literally stole everything
from this movie from.
And there's an interview with Paul Stanley
from KISS and it starts tight.
And he's clearly under a sheet and he's talking
and just about life and rock and roll.
And then it pops out, why, he's literally
in bed with four girls, who are also naked.
And that's how he just did his interview.
And that was normal.
So, I thought, "OK.
I totally get this."
So, me personally, this music was like really
the wallpaper of my life because--.
And back when MTV actually played music videos,
every one of these things was on every second.
So, whether or not you're listening to it
on the radio or had all the--.
What would they have been now?
They would've been cassettes, or had the cassette.
>>Male Presenter: On your Walkman.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
On your Walkman.
There was no way to avoid this music.
So, it was so entrenched in my consciousness.
And then, when they asked me to do it and
I went and saw the play, I was barely watching
the play because I was freaked out about how
out of their minds, the audience was just
crazy for it.
They were practically eating their seats.
And they were all straight.
In a Broadway musical.
And they knew all the words.
[laughter]
And I thought, "I'll never know an experience
like this again.
This is an unheard-of moment."
And so, I thought if I can combine all of
my skills and get that kind of audience, it
would be an amazing experience.
>>Male Presenter: And was it one of the biggest
challenges of actually working on this movie?
Just getting the songs out of your head?
I mean, if you hear the same songs--.
>>Adam Shankman: Oh, yeah.
God.
It's, well now--.
>>Male Presenter: every single one up there,
you just--.
>>Adam Shankman: Well, they're on the radio
all the time.
I mean, "We're Not Gonna Take It" is now like
a hotel commercial--the theme song.
So, and they use it as a bit about coffee,
about "we're not gonna take bad coffee anymore."
[laughter]
I'm sure that's what the song was originally
intended to be about.
[laughter]
They went back to the roots.
But the biggest challenge for me with this,
because it is jukebox musical and this is
the nature of jukebox musicals, is that the
songs are not written for a character.
So, you have to mold everything around those
words coming out of people's mouths.
I mean, in this movie, there's the production.
There's the numbers that are presentational
on stage, and there's dialogue and there's
monologues--stuff going on in people's heads.
So, it was just a matter of putting the right
words and keeping everybody who they are and
real.
As real as you can be in this world.
But by the way, this is a real world for me
because I actually do sing and dance regularly
in my life and am a true embarrassment to
the gym.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: So, where were you in 1987?
>>Adam Shankman: 1987, I was in New York.
And I was more of like a club kid.
Back then, I was more New Wave-y.
But I got back to LA--I'm from LA--and I got
back to LA.
Yeah.
I had left school and I was a waiter and had
just started doing, I started working in theater--musical
theater.
>>Male Presenter: 'Cause you went to Julliard
at 18 and--.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
Yeah.
And I dropped out soon after.
>>Male Presenter: But you actually got in
without actually having had a dance class.
>>Adam Shankman: Having ever had a dance class.
I know.
I was a weird one.
I was Flashdance.
It was literally, it was me in leg warmers,
dancing.
[laughter]
And I had never taken a dance class and they
let me in.
And I got into every school that I auditioned
for without ever having had a dance class,
which all it means is I'm a good imitator.
Do you know what I mean?
It's like I knew where to put my leg at the
right moment, whatever.
But that was really crazy, that audition,
because they have a very strict ballet bar.
And I didn't know what any of the words were.
I kind of knew what a plie was, but past that,
I had never heard it.
So, I'm just looking at everybody, trying
to just get past the audition.
It was crazy.
>>Male Presenter: And New York didn't really
hold you in sway?
And you, back home for?
>>Adam Shankman: Well, honestly, I had just
done some summer stock and I had my first
relationship.
And it ended really weirdly.
He flipped out and so, I moved and my parents
said, "Just please come back home."
And I moved back to LA.
This was my dream to become a video music
producer.
And then, I ended up working at a restaurant.
And then, got in, I auditioned for another
Janet Jackson "Escapade" video, so I'm in
that.
And then, I got in, I did the American Music
Awards for her, same thing.
And then, I got in the Oscars that year, which
was the year Paula Abdul choreographed it.
Yes, I'm a Paula Abdul dancer.
[laughter]
And soon, right thereafter, I lied my way
into my first choreography gig and never looked
back.
I was only 24 when I started choreographing.
So--.
>>Male Presenter: And having grown up in Hollywood,
you probably had folks you knew, or friends
of parents, who were in the movie business
in some way, shape, or form.
You never really though about movies as such,
or--?
>>Adam Shankman: Well, I never wanted to be
a director.
God, that never even occurred to me.
But what the choreography thing what was really
cool was I had all these friends who are part
of a young Hollywood organization called Young
Artists United.
And my friend Patrick, who actually started
Rock the Vote, was the head of this thing.
And it was all people like Judd Nelson and
Sarah Jessica Parker and Robert Downey, who
I lived with when they were together.
They were my roommates.
[chuckles]
They would go around to schools and preach
like not doing drugs and drinking.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: They did their research.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
And so, what started happening with all these
friends of mine is they started to just become
movie stars.
And they started to ask for me on their movies.
I was their friend who was the choreographer
and so, that was them flexing their new muscles.
And so, that's how I started in the movie
thing.
But before then, it was a lot of music videos--tons
and tons and tons of music videos.
>>Male Presenter: But your sister is a producer
as well.
Did you guys ever say, "Hey, when we grow
up, we're gonna dive in?"
>>Adam Shankman: No.
We never said that.
No.
We were more like saying, "I hate you."
"No, I hate you."
"I hate you."
We were, she is five years younger than me.
She was working for a company and she produced
the movie "She's All That."
And she asked me to choreograph.
And there's like a big prom scene and there's
some other weird stuff in there that I had
worked on.
And she thought I was good and she thought
I should be a director.
And I said, "But I don't know what you're
talking about."
And I was actually, at that point, I had honestly
choreographed like, 70 movies in like, ten
or eleven years, and a million TV shows and
commercials.
And I was getting a fatigue from directors
that I found to be challenging that they couldn't
make decisions.
And so, I pulled it together and I spent my
own money and made a short film.
And the producer of that short film, without
asking me, submitted it to Sundance and it
got in.
And the rest is history.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: So, it sounds like through
osmosis, just being exposed and on sets--
>>Adam Shankman: Oh, yeah.
>>Male Presenter: all that kind of nuance
and the different roles within--.
>>Adam Shankman: I did not go to school for
that.
>>Male Presenter: the industry, you just got
exposed to it and took it on.
So, script writing.
>>Adam Shankman: Well, the best part is that
my parents--my mom's a shrink and my dad was
a lawyer--so my whole approach to actors is
assess and negotiate.
[laughter]
And it's on a case-by-case basis.
It's how it's worked for me.
>>Male Presenter: And as far as assess and
negotiate with regards to just every component
of the movie industry because it's always,
I think, from the outside, you pick up on
different words as far as something being
green-lit and multiple producers versus an
executive producer and all these different
roles.
And it seems just like, well, it's obviously
herding cats and it's extremely complex and
difficult, but how did you get comfortable
in each of those roles?
So, for example, just getting to how scripts
work?
How script formats worked?
Act one, two, three, when certain types of
events should happen?
>>Adam Shankman: Well, I'd been through so
many and I've seen so many people go up and
I've seen so many people come down.
And being a crew member, as a choreographer,
I'm just a crew member.
And knowing--.
And you really get to know--.
And by the way, as a choreographer, I am also
directing the actors in the scenes.
I was hired to do a lot of scenes with the
leads in the thing 'cause scripts say "and
then they dance."
And so, that's where I come in.
So, I had already worked a lot with actors.
I knew a lot of actors growing up.
My dad represented a bunch.
And I saw, I never learned anything from a
good director.
I literally never learned anything from a
I learned a lot from the bad ones because
I was like, "God, I never wanna be that person.
I never wanna treat people that way."
There's a long list of "I never want."
And so, but the good ones are just magic.
Like, you don't understand what's happening.
They're just creating something great.
And when I started directing, I just, you
just go with your gut.
It's all weird opportunities.
And I never take it for granted that this
is my job and this is an opportunity and that
this is a privilege and that these people
are entrusting me with a bunch of money.
And the actors are trusting me with their
careers.
And I take it seriously in that I'm not better
than any of the project, the this, the actor,
the any of it.
So really, again in the assess and negotiate
thing, what I learned very early on is choosing
which swords you're gonna fall on because
there are so many battles that you wage.
And some of them feel very personal and they're
not, but they feel like it.
And certainly the more I've gone on, the more
I get frustrated because I feel like I've
proven myself literally over and over and
over and over again in so many different areas.
And but it is everybody's job to treat you
without trust.
It feels like they're all really behind you
until that moment, you know?
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Adam Shankman: Then, it's just like a disaster.
And then, I have a tough side.
And I get--.
My eyes narrow and I can--.
Once again, that's where the shrink and lawyer
part comes in, which is really good is because
I go for everybody's Achilles heel.
I go right for what's gonna hurt them the
most, you know?
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Well, as you shifted into
different roles, oftentimes you actually were
doing two roles.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: So, you'd choreograph and
you would direct.
>>Adam Shankman: Choreographing, directing,
producing--it's all part of it.
I mean, and you can't really effectively--.
I mean, let's put it this way.
"Hairspray" was much easier because I had
choreographed it for me because I was choreographing
for camera.
So, when "Rock of Ages," I had, there was
only five weeks of prep and it was a much
bigger movie--same budget as "Hairspray."
It was literally, we were like, "You have
to back into a number."
And so, I said OK.
And we did it.
But I hired a very good colleague, who I think
is one of the greatest choreographers on Earth
right now.
It's this woman, Mia Michaels, and she choreographed
it.
And we have some Mia fans.
[laughter]
And then, she's more of like, an artists-type
and wasn't used to working on strict production
schedules and "I need this now," and yadda
yadda yadda.
On top of which, I was asking her to do stuff
that was so like she had never done before,
which were sex.
She does not sexualize anything and I have
all these strippers in the movie, boy band
choreography, which she was like--.
I was like, "No, it actually needs to be the
Roger Rabbit.
It needs to actually be--."
Like I want them to go like this.
[laughter]
She was like, "I don't know who I am anymore."
And she'd cry and it was amazing.
[laughter]
And so that was that.
But that was hard because I would come in
to watch a rehearsal and I wouldn't be familiar
with all the stuff right away.
But, you know?
That's what I do, so I was very quick to figure
it out.
There were times when we would be shooting
and she hadn't finished the number.
And so, she was making it up as we were going
along.
And it was four o'clock in the morning and
I'm like, "Can you show me what's next?"
And she's like, "I'm not sure what's next."
And I was like, "Can we figure it out?"
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: But oftentimes, those can
be the best moments for inspiration, right,
when you've just gone through the other side.
>>Adam Shankman: I mean, I, listen.
I'm an adrenaline junkie.
So, I live for that stuff.
And actually, it's in the most dire, most
horrible moments that I go the most calm,
you know?
>>Male Presenter: Well, back to being able
to preserve your energy so you can put your,
the most in the right spots--?
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: When you start to take on
producing, directing, and choreography, how
much more time would that add to a movie being,
when you're planning because you're on the
set, you just--?
>>Adam Shankman: You know what?
I'm not really good at living in the world.
I'm really good at living on set.
And so, I'm just happy there.
And so, it's all good.
Do you know what I mean?
I would love to say, "Oh, it's so grueling."
It's not.
I love it so much.
[laughter]
It's so much a better place for me.
And me, running amok in the world, bad, bad,
bad, bad, bad.
So, I just started writing my first screenplay,
which I was very excited about, that I actually
have the nerve to like, think that I could
look at a blank page and have something to
say.
I imagine it's gonna be horrible, but I'm
excited.
And like, I'm not talking about--
>>Male Presenter: You'd be old?
>>Adam Shankman: writing.
I'm writing a children's book series, potentially.
So, I've started doing that.
>>Male Presenter: In addition to the screen
plays and then you're also--.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
Well, that for some reason is much easier
for me.
I don't know why.
>>Male Presenter: Children's series.
>>Adam Shankman: Do you know why?
[laughter]
I come, like, a lot of my background is children's
theater, so I'm very versed in that.
So, and it's weird 'cause I'm like a dirty
old man.
[laughter]
So, it's weird.
I mean, I'm not, but I-- [laughs]
[laughter]
Not really, but I'm like a person who's lived
in the world.
Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: You just happen to choreograph
strippers.
>>Adam Shankman: I mean, but the strippers
in my movie are like Cirque du Soleil performers.
They're like, they're non-strippers.
They're professional pole specialists.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Now, trying to actually
control that environment, because to your
point, that time was so drugs, sex, and rock
and roll, and obviously, this is a look into
that at a window.
Did some of that seep into the environment
on the set and you had to keep that control?
Or, were you enthusiastically--everyone was
super?
>>Adam Shankman: Oh, God.
No, no, no, no.
Everybody's super.
I mean, don't get me wrong.
When you're around Tom, there's just no room
for any of that--Tom Cruise.
Tom.
[laughter]
So, yep.
Tom.
He sets a bar of professionalism that is so
beyond anything you can possibly imagine.
His enthusiasm, his energy.
He's there two hours before the crew.
It's embarrassing 'cause you're constantly
trying to live up to that, that standard of
professionalism and commitment.
And that's my whole thing.
It's like, "Look.
My life is too short and living on sets, they
have to be happy sets or I'll kill people."
Like, you're happy or you're fired.
It's basically my philosophy, so I insist
that it be a fertile, happy environ--.
I mean, even when I was making "A Walk to
Remember," which is and then she died of cancer
movie, I was a happy set.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Well, I think that must
help bringing an ensemble cast.
I mean, that's quite a cast.
It's Paul Giamatti.
It's Mary J. Blige.
It's Tom.
It's Alec Baldwin.
>>Adam Shankman: Everybody.
Yeah, yeah.
It's, and everybody in a different level of
something and definitely big personalities.
And but, in a musical, because it's none of
their forte--except for Catherine--that Catherine
Zeta-Jones.
Catherine.
[laughter]
Other than Catherine Zeta-Jones, because they're
out of their comfort zone, everybody was really
into it and really, incredibly--.
You know, it's a hard thing.
You have to really rehearse.
I mean, Tom Cruise literally willed a totally
different person onto himself--the way he
walks, his singing.
He was singing four, five hours a day for
that many months.
And I got scared he was gonna blow out his
voice.
But it's insane.
I mean, it's amazing the product that comes
out of that.
For this, this movie is just like a party,
but the work that went into it was incredible.
>>Male Presenter: And as far as discovering
what you're gonna do next, is your personal
screen play at the top of the list, or?
>>Adam Shankman: Oh, God.
No, no, no, no.
That piece of crap is never gonna see the
light of day.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: It's a good story.
>>Adam Shankman: No, no, no.
It's very, very cathartic and a lot of it
actually has to do with dealing with my demons
from when I was first coming out.
And so, what could be more boring than that?
So, I'm in there doing that, but my next movie
is a movie called "This is Where I Leave You."
It's based on a Jonathan Tropper novel of
the same title.
And what?
>>Female #1: [ ]
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah, Zac's doing it.
Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: Zac.
>>Adam Shankman: Oh, Zac.
[laughter]
Yes.
Jason Bateman, Zac Efron, Leslie Mann.
I think Sudeikis, Malin Akerman.
Goldie Hawn, after ten years, I got Goldie
playing the mom, who's basically playing my
mother, which is going to be fantastic.
[laughter]
And she's a character who's just, or many,
many years, she was like the Erica Jong of
parenting--the books.
Like, she was like the Dr. Spock, but hot.
And in writing her books, she basically revealed
all the secrets of her family.
So, her kids all hate her.
But she's going on a book tour.
And the father just died and she's just gotten
a giant boob job and she keeps trying to show
her boobs to the kids, like, during their
father's funeral.
And it's, I cannot wait to get her out there
doing that.
This is gonna be so cool.
I'm so excited.
[laughter]
But yeah.
More casting announcements to come.
And then, after that, I'm supposed to do a
giant green screen action adventure version
of "The Nutcracker."
'Cause I don't wanna take on the dancing version
because I'm not George Balanchine and that's
too scary.
So, it's more like in the "Alice in Wonderland,"
"Snow White and the Huntsman" vein of "Nutcracker."
But like, yeah.
I mean, I went from this "Rock of Ages" of
people like crazy singing and dancing to literally
a movie about people sitting in chairs talking.
>>Male Presenter: And how does it go about
actually keeping in touch with the projects
as they're evolving to then finally say, "OK.
I'm gonna be attached to this and this is
actually happening?"
'Cause oftentimes, you hear this stuff--
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: it's almost there.
It's almost there.
Oh, it's not.
And then, it's back.
And how do you--?
>>Adam Shankman: Oh, I've had lots of movies
fall apart.
I've had lots of them.
I mean, a couple of my movies that I made
happened simply because other ones fell apart.
And then, they slid one in 'cause I just wanted
to work.
And, 'cause for me, it's perpetual school.
I get paid to learn about how to keep doing
this.
And there's reasons why names like "Cheaper
by the Dozen Two" are on my resume.
You know about that?
I was supposed to direct "Four Christmases"
and that fell apart at Disney.
And they literally were like, "Oh, we've got
this great family comedy and there's a spy
and it's good.
And we're pay a lot of money."
[laughter]
And then, by the way, it's Vin Diesel.
And I was like, "What are you talking about?
What do you mean I'm making a Vin Diesel family
comedy?"
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: It was the "by the way"
after you signed something?
>>Adam Shankman: I told the president of--this
is weird.
The president of Disney at the time was this
brilliant woman named Nina Jacobson, who I
actually went to the same high school.
And she just produced "Hunger Games."
And she was just like, "Yeah.
You're gonna make this movie for me."
And my deal was there.
Me and my sister had a deal with Disney at
the time.
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
I'm making a Vin Diesel family comedy."
[laughter]
"How much are you gonna pay me?"
I mean, it was, but it ended up being an incredibly
fun experience, that movie.
That movie was, I can live with that one.
>>Male Presenter: And is it, usually the contract
now is to get a director attached to something
first to get momentum after [ ]?
>>Adam Shankman: It's all different ways.
It's director or actor attachments sometimes,
before directors.
Because you know now, actors all have deals
and they're all producers and it's like, managers
are producers.
It's all very, there's no one way it works.
>>Male Presenter: And then, coming from an
engineering company, or at least personally,
sometimes you wonder about all the great movies
that Hollywood makes and all the not so great
movies.
Is there a way to engineer it so you can somehow
produce more great ones and less bad ones?
>>Adam Shankman: Not really.
I mean, I haven't run a studio, so I don't
know exactly how the notions of quota and
all of that, or how that happens.
But you can just hope for good scripts.
I mean, I've basically, up until "Hairspray"
everything that I had done had at one time
been considered a very broken piece of material
and I had to go in and--.
I was the fixer.
And then, "Hairspray" was great.
And then there was another one.
And then, this was, "Rock of Ages" was pretty
funky because some of the construct of the
play, it was very breaking fourth wall.
It was all narration.
It was high camp.
And it was stuff that I was like, "Well, to
emotionally get the audience invested, I'm
gonna have to--"
>>Male Presenter: Tweak the character.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
Do a little magic.
And but, this one that I'm about to do is
just an incredible piece of material.
So, I feel super lucky.
Like, really lucky.
Like, really, really lucky.
So, like you don't get it how lucky I am.
[laughter]
Like, I'm gonna talk to you really for a long
time about how lucky I am right now.
No, but yeah.
But quality control?
Hollywood's never been known for that.
We're, that's not our game.
We leave that to the Weinstein Company.
We just, we cross our fingers and really hope
for the best.
Let's put it this way.
You know this.
Nobody goes out trying to do shitty work.
>>Male Presenter: Yup.
>>Adam Shankman: So, and these things are
very difficult and they're labors of love.
And one, it is a year of your life and you
can find your life just passing you by if
you're making one of them.
So, it's just like, there's a lot of trying
to be conscientious about what it is that
you're doing.
OK.
How great is this?
I had an assistant that quit.
And he came up to me and said, "Well, I got
this opportunity to direct a movie."
And I was like, "Matthew, that is fantastic.
What is it?"
He said, "Murder on Cheerleader Island."
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Was that two, or--?
>>Adam Shankman: That is not a joke.
That was actually the name of the project.
And I said, "Don't tell me.
It's about a series of murders on an island
during cheer leading camp."
He's like, "Yeah."
And I was like, "Wow."
[laughter]
"I think you should take the opportunity."
'Cause everybody just wants to direct.
They think, I was like, "But why do you wanna
direct if it's gonna be just like, 'Murder
on Cheerleader Island?'"
I mean, I get it, but really?
>>Male Presenter: I think we can start taking
some questions from the audience if anybody
wants to line up.
>>Adam Shankman: I'm very shy.
So--.
[laughter]
[pause]
Oh, he's not gonna ask me a question.
He's going to the bathroom.
[laughs] Awesome.
>>Male Presenter: Can you just jump over to
the mic, so we can catch it on VC?
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
[pause]
>>Male #1: Went and saw "Rock of Ages" last
night.
It was wonderful.
Thank you so much.
[applause]
It was a wonderful, wonderful show.
>>Adam Shankman: Thank you.
I always get very nervous where I went and
saw it and--?
>>Male #1: My wife and I had a great time.
So, thank you very much.
>>Adam Shankman: Ah, straight guy.
>>Male #1: Sorry about that.
Sorry about that.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
>>Male #1: Which leads into my questions,
because I have two sons.
Well, actually I have four sons.
>>Adam Shankman: How do you not know how many
sons you have?
[laughter]
>>Male #1: It's only about, it's the two oldest
that I wanted to mention.
They're seven and six.
And we have a tradition of watching musicals
all the time.
And so, my question for you is doing so many
different musicals, you've had the "Rock of
Ages" project and "Hairspray" and then the
"Nutcracker" one, which I'm very excited to
hear about.
What is the role--?
My boys really enjoy the classic Rodgers and
Hammerstein sort of stuff, or even the "West
Side Story" stuff.
>>Adam Shankman: Uh-oh.
[laughter]
>>Male #1: Do those types of musicals exist,
or could they still exist in this world like
new material?
Can those things be rebooted in your thoughts?
>>Adam Shankman: You mean as films?
>>Male #1: Rebooted as anything.
To expose--.
>>Adam Shankman: I mean, they are, they.
>>Male #1: New material, updated material
to a younger generation.
>>Adam Shankman: I mean, they are endless.
They're perennial on Broadway.
I mean, there's constantly a new--.
They just had a really successful run of "South
Pacific" and all of that.
So, it's, they exist there.
Making them now, I think, where they would
exist best and most is probably in cable now
because I don't think the studios want to--.
I mean, they're making another "A Star is
Born."
Clint Eastwood is actually directing it, which
is fascinating.
I don't know.
I mean, there's always people coming up like,
"Let's redo Mame."
And I'm like, "Really?
Redoing Mame?
OK."
And they were doing them on TV for a while.
They did "Annie."
And Craig Zadan and Neil Meron are the producers
who actually were on "Hairspray" and had a
real nice run of those.
But what audiences have a tough time, what
studios have a tough time with is financing
something that you don't feel a big audience
for.
And it's safer to do something like on TV,
something like "A Sound of Music."
Well, first of all, why would you want to
remake something that is so brilliant.
I don't wanna do that.
People are always asking me, "Hey, why don't
we redo 'West Side Story'?"
And I'm like, "Why don't you go kill yourself.
I have no interest in doing that."
[laughter]
But, I mean, the answer is kind of no in terms
of movie.
They are trying to do a remake, and they haven't
for a while, of "My Fair Lady."
That's coming down the pike.
I think Keira Knightley is who I heard.
Is that right?
>>Male #1: And maybe I should clarify that
maybe it's not so much a reboot, but what
if it's things that are in the same type of
genre, or I guess, the same--.
"Rock of Ages," I can't take my seven and
six year old to.
And it will probably be ten years before--.
>>Adam Shankman: You can.
You just have to take them out for popcorn
when Malin is having sex with her on the air
hockey table.
>>Male #1: They'll be so full of popcorn,
they're not gonna make it home.
[laughter]
But the--.
>>Adam Shankman: Wait till you see the extended
version, what I had to cut out.
[laughter]
My sister called it the extends-ded version.
But yeah.
I mean, listen.
"Hairspray," great for families.
I mean, that movie did more for me with kids
than anything in the world.
That was a huge deal for me 'cause it also
opened up parent/children, parent and child
conversations about racism, bullying, why
didn't they want Tracy?
'Cause that wasn't--.
I mean, look.
At the center of that story is a movie about
a fat girl who ends racism.
How do you hate that movie?
You know what I mean?
[laughter]
It's like, and get Zac Efron.
So, that one was kind of easy.
But I, you know what?
My godson, who's two and a half, if I can
get him away from the "Backyardigans," he
loves musicals.
He loves all the old MGM musicals.
He loves, and those are just, those last forever.
So, the new ones.
I mean, this one was sexy on purpose.
But it's inherent to the world.
But more are gettin' made.
More are going to get made.
>>Female #1: I have three somewhat related
questions about Tom.
[laughter]
>>Adam Shankman: I'm shocked.
>>Female #1: So, why Tom Cruise for the role
of Stacee Jaxx?
>>Adam Shankman: Because he was, he and Suri,
who basically rules that household, was a
huge "Hairspray" fan.
And they watched it probably 300 times, apparently.
And I met him at a party.
Actually, at a one year old's birthday party,
literally sitting in one of those little baby
chairs.
[laughter]
And he pulled up one next to me and started
talking to me.
And he was like, "Hey, I'm Tom Cruise."
And I was like, "I know who you are."
[laughter]
"Why am I in a baby chair meeting Tom Cruise?"
And I actually stood up and it stuck to my
ass.
[laughter]
And this is not a joke.
That is a very true story.
It made him laugh.
He made some reference to wanting to do a
musical and I was like, "That's great and
that will never happen."
And then, this came along and I thought, "God,
if I could get the biggest movie star in the
world to play the biggest rock star in the
world, that would be an event."
And I certainly don't want to put out a musical,
put my name on something that's a musical,
that's my home, what I love the most, and
then not have people want to see it.
Do you know what I mean?
So, I knew, it seems stunty, but it's still--.
By the way, how many people here saw it?
Dude pulled it off, right?
I mean, like that was a lot of work that went
into that.
And it was a gamble that payed off.
>>Female #1: So, kind of a follow-up, how
difficult was it for him to get into that
role and what did he have to do?
>>Adam Shankman: We poured over, I sent him
every book known to mankind about those guys
in this period.
And I talked to him endlessly about channeling
his intensity into being intensely lost.
I wanted him just to like, not be a creature
of the world nobody says no to.
And who, certainly Tom is not a stranger to
the notion of being a star.
So, that was an easy in for him, but he, the
guy doesn't drink.
To my knowledge, he never touched a drug.
So, this is all very foreign.
But he loved, it just made him laugh.
The whole thing, he just thought it was so
weird that I was asking him to do a musical.
And he just loved the opportunity.
And especially being a father and Suri being
this incredibly creative, beautiful child,
he loved having music in the house a lot.
So, it really, it did a lot in their family
life.
Poor Katie has to listen to the guy sing now
every minute of the day, but the dude has
the loudest voice on the planet.
[laughter]
Decibel breaking.
>>Female #1: You touched on just a little
bit, but just in general, what's it like to
work with him?
>>Adam Shankman: He was the greatest experience
of my life.
It was absolutely life-changing just in terms
of having to look at myself and just say,
"How present am I?"
And just really seeing, there's zero ego.
There is just the work.
And that is so inspiring.
That is so inspiring.
There's been a few actors that I've worked
with that have really taught me a lot.
Michelle Pfeiffer was one of them.
Michelle.
[laughter]
On and on.
I've had the great pleasure of working with
people who really take what they do seriously.
And I take what I do seriously because it's
all I do.
I mean, this is amazing.
I can't believe like I'm out of my editing
room or something like that.
It's like, "Oh, wow.
There's people."
So, it's great.
It was amazing.
He is as--.
You know what's really funny about him?
When I look back now and think about the Oprah
thing and any of that stuff, that's real.
Like, he gets that excited.
He's like a kid.
He's guileless and just, he just loves stuff.
And that's real.
And so, sometimes, I was like, "You have to
stop liking this movie so much.
Please, you're killing me, dude."
[laughter]
But he just never wanted it to end.
>>Male #2: Hi.
First, my wife and I saw the movie last night.
We loved it.
It was fantastic.
>>Adam Shankman: Mm-hmm.
>>Male #2: And this question may be a little
bit too close to your work for most people,
but I'm a product manager in the Ads group.
I work on tracking how online advertising
affects people's activities in the real world.
I was wondering if you could tell us anything
you're doing or that you know people in Hollywood
are doing with regards to integrating the
internet into movies and things in general?
>>Adam Shankman: Oh, my God.
It's a huge part of our discussions during
the marketing of a movie.
They're now partially predicting openings
by Twitter activity, trending, certainly an
active Facebook page, anything that's interactive
with a greater audience.
It's a big part of our discussions.
>>Male #2: Do you do anything with things
that are more than just tracking ads, but
also live interaction?
>>Adam Shankman: Aren't I doing it right now?
[laughter]
>>Male #2: Well, I'll give you a specific
example.
In New York, there's a group called Punchdrunk.
>>Adam Shankman: Uh-huh.
>>Male #2: And they do this live, interactive
theater example experience.
And they're working on some things where you
integrate the live experience with the internet
experience, so that there's something happening
simultaneously.
And there are other people who have done things
with voting systems and things like that.
Is there anything experimental you know of
or anything that--?
>>Adam Shankman: I don't know about it, but
I'm sure there is.
A guy who I, a young director who I gave his
first job, he did the second and third "Step
Up" movies--Jon Chu.
And he just did "GI Joe."
YouTube just gave him a whole channel.
And that's all about dance stuff, material.
And I know he's doing lots of different kinds
of work like that.
He's really techy and really into it.
And if anybody knows about it, it's him.
He's actually, he's a pusher on that one.
>>Male #2: OK.
Thank you.
>>Male Presenter: And I think that concept
of 360 degree media is really taking hold
because both in television, so I know you've
directed "Glee" and "Modern Family" and a
lot of those experiences were like heroes.
They existed outside of the film.
So, you actually go to the website or you
go and experience something that's part of
the story line that's actually not just in
television.
>>Adam Shankman: I think that's fantastic.
>>Male Presenter: You can look into the journey
of a film more and more because can give updates
from the set and really for fans to just participate
more.
It's so much easier.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
During the whole making of the movie, I was
doing the, I was trying to keep it as alive
possible--tweeting a lot of pictures, doing
as much as I could.
But we didn't do any live streaming stuff
because out of context, this movie could feel
weird.
Do you know what I mean?
It looks a little odd.
I mean, I think that audiences for this movie
aren't exactly gonna know what they're in
for when they go in because it is an unusual
hybrid of a movie.
And it's hard to express the tone of the movie
in the advertising.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Kind of?
Weird?
Like, you don't really, I'm just assuming
from your reaction that it was better than
you thought it was gonna be.
So, which I'm happy to take.
[laughter]
By the way.
So, that's all good.
And that creates word of mouth.
I'd rather have a low expectation with a high
result, you know?
>>Male Presenter: Well, I think that because
it has such a frame of reference that everybody--.
You hear the songs and you automatically remember
and associate with those.
And that brings both good stuff and possible
baggage, so yeah.
I think that's good.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
And the same with cast members.
>>Female #2: Hi.
Thanks for coming, by the way.
>>Adam Shankman: My pleasure.
>>Female #2: Yeah.
>>Adam Shankman: I'm loving this, by the way.
This is fun for me.
>>Female #2: Comment.
The school prom choreography in "She's All
That" was the best thing that ever happened
to me in sixth grade.
So, it was awesome.
>>Adam Shankman: That was me.
[laughter]
>>Female #2: Thank you for that.
[laughs] I love it.
I love it.
>>Adam Shankman: Yep, yep, yep.
I had about two hours to put that whole thing
together.
And I'm not kidding.
That was actually, they literally brought
in the dancers.
I taught them it in two hours in the lobby.
It was the Cerritos Auto Square where we shot
that in like, Long Beach.
And the next day, we were literally shooting
it all day.
It was the craziest thing.
I was just like, "Hollywood."
>>Female #2: Good times.
Yeah.
But my question is, Nicholas Sparks came a
few weeks ago promoting "The Lucky One."
>>Adam Shankman: Uh-huh.
>>Female #2: And I know he wrote "A Walk to
Remember."
I was wondering--.
>>Adam Shankman: I have that song.
I have two of them.
>>Female #2: Definitely.
So, I was wondering, what's the dynamics between
working with authors in movies that are adapted
from novels?
Like, what's that dynamic with working with
those authors as a director and things like
that?
>>Adam Shankman: Well, I can only speak to
mine.
>>Female #2: Yeah.
>>Adam Shankman: To my experiences, which
is during "Walk to Remember," that was, I
was very, very, it was very precarious because
I was changing the whole time period of the
movie and it was about his sister.
So, I was very nervous about how he was going
to react.
>>Female #2: 'Cause it was originally set
in the '40s.
>>Adam Shankman: Yes.
Yeah.
And so, what I made sure what I did--and I
did this actually with John Waters in "Hairspray"
and I'm doing it right now with Jonathan Tropper
on "This is Where I Leave You"--I have unending
conversations with them where I really keep
them in the loop.
And they feel really appreciated and part
of the process.
And I don't make any dramatic move without
talking to them.
And it's not like what they say is gonna influence
me a lot because I have the story as I see
it in my head.
And once again, that's the only frame of reference
I can do it from.
If I try to live in somebody else's box, it
just won't work.
So, I just have Nick really close.
I kept, and then "Last Song," I don't know
if you know the lore behind this, but this
was crazy.
And this is so pure Nick.
That Nick.
[laughter]
That my, we got a call from Disney saying
Miley Cyrus, her favorite movie is "Walk to
Remember."
And she wants to do a movie like that.
"Do you have anything?
Can you come up with something?"
And my sister said, "Let me think."
And she literally had the nerve.
She called Nicholas Sparks and he took her
call and she said, "Do you have anything you
could dust off?
Anything in your drawer that might--?"
He's like, "No, but I've been thinking that
my next book should be for young audiences
again.
So, let me think about this."
And he called her back the next day and he
said, "I have it.
Here's what it is.
And I'm gonna write the book and the script
at the same time."
>>Female #2: Thanks.
Wow.
>>Adam Shankman: "And I'm writing it for her.
And I'll release the book right in time for
it to precede the opening of the movie."
And that's how that happened.
And it literally just happened.
And I was like, that was crazy.
Literally the book, "Last Song" was written
to make sure that Miley Cyrus had a movie
version of it to be in.
>>Female #2: Wow.
>>Adam Shankman: Yeah.
Hollywood.
Scary.
[laughter]
>>Female #2: Wow.
Cool.
>>Adam Shankman: So, but my thing is just
to keep them there.
And I've been very successful in terms of
my relationships with the authors as a result
of keeping, being very, very respectful.
John Waters sent me, after he saw "Hairspray,"
sent me the best email of my life.
He was driving back on the Acela train from
New York.
He was going back to Baltimore.
And he just wrote, "Just saw the movie.
You've made me the proudest grandfather on
Earth.
Love, John."
And I was like, "I'm so happy."
[laughter]
>>Female #2: Cool.
Thank you.
>>Male Presenter: I think we have time for
one more question.
>>Adam Shankman: I'll just be shorter in my
answers.
Sorry.
>>Female #3: Do you have any examples or anecdotes
about the adversity faced being a untrained
dancer, choreographer and bursting into that
world?
>>Adam Shankman: The adversity of it?
>>Female #3: Yeah, like did you receive any
backlash from--?
>>Adam Shankman: Oh, oh.
God, yeah.
I was treated really badly by the--.
I was treated well by choreographers.
I was treated very badly by the teachers because
I just had no training.
And but they treated me because I was embarrassed
to tell them that.
They treated me like I had like, 13 years
of terrible, terrible training that they had
to undo.
And I didn't want to expose the fact that
I had no training because then, it could have
created a fuffle in that how would they let
me in, all this stuff.
And the Julliard philosophy is to break you
down and create the best technician possible,
so that you're technically prepared.
So, yeah.
I got beat up a lot.
I got beat up by the teachers a lot.
That was hard.
It was psychologically and emotionally very
hard for me.
I'm still clearly damaged as you can tell.
[laughter]
>>Female #3: But you made it.
Thank you.
>>Male Presenter: Very well.
On behalf of Google, thanks everybody for
coming.
[applause]
[rock ballad]